should you upgrade to the new iPhone 15
from an older iPhone or buy a 13 or 14
since apple is still selling them for
much lower prices well I'm going to give
you guys all of the info and I think
you're going to be really surprised I'm
gonna start out with the external
changes because this was something that
I think is really cool and I was not
expecting the colors are now a lot more
muted than the very saturated bright
colors of the previous iPhones and the
colors actually embedded through the
single piece of glass it's actually
built into the foundation of it itself
and we have a new textured matte finish
on the glass instead of the shiny finish
now the older iPhones they got a ton of
fingerprints and the new iPhone 15 well
is just like the pros the next update is
the new USB type c port for the first
time ever the iPads the MacBooks and the
iPhones have the same connector now I
know you probably have a bunch of
lightning cables but I would say this is
a huge selling point because it makes it
easy to share your charger with
different devices and also with friends
that might have an Android phone now
unfortunately the speeds are still the
slow USB type 2 speeds for transfers so
if you want to get the faster speed you
have to go with the pro but most people
just use that cable or Max save for
charging and they use iCloud now you do
get a new braided cable so it is a very
nice one and also makes it a little bit
more durable as well and the next big
change is the dynamic Island Apple added
this last year to the pro phones but now
it is here on the standard iPhones and
let me tell you using it over the last
year has been awesome there are so many
shortcuts and so much information that
can pop up for example if I'm using my
timer if I want to quickly access music
and just showing me directions for
navigation and a ton of other stuff and
the timing is perfect because many
third-party applications are now adding
extra features to use it now that it's
been out for about a year and I think
this is a huge selling point it gets rid
of that
ugly Notch now it does cut into your
content because it's kind of floating
there but I would say this is a big
upgrade over the previous phones and
it's the first time in a while that
there's a difference on the front of the
phone now the next one I was not
expecting at all we gasped when Apple
showed this off and that is the fact
that we are getting the super Retina xdr
display that you only got on the pro
phones this thing is able to reach 1600
nits for HDR in standard or lighting the
brightness is actually higher as well
and it can hit up to 2 000 nits when you
are outside in the sun and now this has
been absolutely amazing a real world
difference where you're outside it's
bright but your screen is now way
brighter making it really easy to see to
enjoy what you're looking at and this is
a massive upgrade compared to the older
phones now the screen sizes are
technically the same but if you look at
the resolution it has actually gone up
by just a little bit and that is because
the iPhone 15 is slightly taller than
the 14 and the 13 and 12 but with that
it actually weighs one gram less I don't
know how they achieve that because we do
have a bigger battery inside we have the
new cameras that we will touch on and
some other changes that Apple didn't
mention but that is pretty cool to see
and with that we also have a new
contoured Edge which means that the
phone is going to be more comfortable to
hold in your hand we still have the flat
sides like before which gives you really
good grip but now with that contoured
edge it's just going to feel nicer in
the hand now before I move on I've got
to talk about something that is
impacting more and more people these
days which is depression and even more
common anxiety which is something that
I've personally struggled with which
made me withdraw from and people I love
made it hard to work and just not enjoy
life and that is why I am excited to
tell you about today's sponsor better
help betterhelp's mission is to make
therapy more affordable and accessible
through their online platform which is
conveniently fully remote allowing you
to quickly fill out a few questions to
instantly match you with a professional
therapist in as little as a few days to
start getting you the help you need to
work through those issues and because
finding a therapist that fits you is a
little like dating if you don't really
fit with that therapist you can easily
switch to a new therapist at no
additional cost without stressing about
insurance who's in your network or
anything like that so if you're
struggling consider online therapy with
better help just tap or click the link
in the description or visit
betterhelp.com maxtech for 10 off your
first month of Professional Therapy with
better help today now I previously
mentioned the bigger batteries Apple
said that on stage but the battery life
is rated about the same as it was before
now internally we have a lot of
differences is so the real world screen
on time can actually be better and I
will explain why we have the a16 chip
that came in the iPhone 14 pro so that
is now in here and that also means that
we have better CPU performance graphics
performance and better efficiency now
what is brand new is the second gen
Ultra wide band chip this is the first
time that this update has come out to
that chip and Apple's going to be using
this one for a long time now one really
cool thing is that it works three times
further away so if you're going to be
tracking down an air tag or maybe
another device like a friend you can
actually do it really far away and it
will guide you with Precision finding to
your friends and that is really really
cool this ship will also be used for a
lot of other things in the future so
that is one reason if you're buying a
new phone to go with the 15. now another
thing that is new is the x70 the modem
now Apple did not mention this but we
have had 5G ever since the iPhone 12.
and every year the connection actually
gets better and with that we have the
emergency SOS with satellite now that
was added to the iPhone 14s but now they
are adding roadside assistance so it's
using the same technology but it's more
useful and that's actually both on the
15 and the 14 it's going to get added so
if that's something you find yourself in
areas where you have no signal at all I
would definitely consider that now the
next change is a huge one and that is
the cameras now we have a 48 megapixel
main camera and this is using a brand
new sensor with actual better technology
than the sensor in the iPhone 15 pro has
it has sensor shift image stabilization
it has a new lens and it's doing quad
pixel binning so it can combine pixels
together the focusing is much improved
and there's a lot of software
improvements now one thing that is super
cool is that unlike last year with the
pros well if you take a photo it is now
defaulted to a 24 megapixel image so you
have more detail there but what Apple
didn't say is that you can actually
switch it to HAF Max which we saw on
screen and it'll record a 48 megapixel
image that is compressed and doesn't
take up a lot of room now I've been
shooting 48 megapixel shots with my 14
pro for about a year and the detail is
incredible looks more natural but with
that you had to use Pro Rock convert it
yourself this is all done automatically
so this is a massive Improvement now
with that sensor you also have a 2X
telephoto mode now built in so that is
really sweet because it just improves
the zoom camera and likely for portrait
shots you won't be stuck with just a
wide angle camera that can cause
distortions and stuff like that it'll
look a lot more natural so if you like
portraits this is a really big
improvement with that Zoom shots are
going to look way better than before
because you have four times the
resolution and you can also zoom in
twice as much than before too which is a
limitation with the 14 and previous you
could only do 5x so that is really nice
colors have been updated we have smart
hdr5 so you have better low light better
portraits overall and what's really cool
is that you can take a photo and then
shift where the focus is to another
subject and then with that you can take
a regular photo not in portrait mode and
then you can add portion mode later
because all that data is being saved
with that I have to point out nighttime
photos because this is where the old
regular iPhone struggled the Pro Models
had lidar so you could do night mode and
portrait at the same time and it looked
so much better but finally this is going
to be fixed now the prices have stayed
exactly the same you still get the same
amount of storage at base as well so
that didn't change but of course like I
mentioned you can get the iPhone 14 for
100 less than the 15 and even the 13 for
200 less and then of course you can buy
used phones but with all this info that
I shared with you guys I have to say
that I am actually a lot more impressed
with this year's iPhone 15 than I am
with the 15 Pro update we have so many
new features that are packed into the 15
things that Apple would lock down with
Hardware or software to make the regular
iPhone worse than the pro model but this
year I was just shocked by how much they
gave it and I think this is the best
regular iphone update in very very many
years so honestly I would say that if
you are trying to decide between
upgrading I would absolutely do it if
you have a 14 and you're thinking about
it I would still say yes if you're on
the fence of course most people don't
upgrade their phone every year but if
you have a 13 or a 12 this is the year
to upgrade if you're thinking about just
going with the regular iPhone not the
Pro Models so let me know your thoughts
if you're going to be upgrading or
buying an iPhone 15 I want to hear you
guys opinion once again check out
betterhelp down below click that Circle
above to subscribe and check out one of
those great videos right over there this
has been Max and I'll see you in the
next one
[Music]
foreign